welcome to this video of our lawn so I
thought on so I played this guy recently
right
Alonzo Rozelle okay let's see what we
get okay this line yeah I remember that
I have played this against him kind of
it is a little bit him I think I played
Bishop d7 to complain where are you
it's not I'm not a huge deal you want
Bishop a6 as a possibility and I played
it too quickly to b7 but I don't think
it's terrible mmm Black has quite some
nice space on the queenside him let's
see how it's playing at Queen b5 is
never a problem
Bishop c6 not losing a piece I'm just
trying to grab lots of space on the
Queen side
I wonder there should be seven castles
if I get this in without any problems
I'm definitely okay I'm always asking
myself what am I going to do if you play
something like c4 I'm a just taking this
probably not you should be a six I don't
know what white should do it's not easy
at all I was never attracted to this
early g3m always thought that b5 should
be good okay so
just those streets let's see you know is
coming with this okay
so I'm going to aren't going to take and
just claim that this cannot be that
great white um okay he has c4 as a final
idea I wonder if I should play c5 it's
it's really I'm back I'm really backward
in development here but it's okay I hope
this works it is a bit risky to lane
castling even more but there should be
seven c4 looked a bit better for white I
think okay so he's trying form the chip
Quinby first check what I'm saying maybe
I should actually start with just
capturing yeah why not keep it simple
and get this that they capture that
takes the detects if I'm out of them out
of the game of course my bishop is
looking silly on a but his Bishop on g2
is not much better
hmm yeah that's not very exciting but if
I get castles in without any problem I'm
totally fine and I don't see what he's
doing really to prevent it I'm just
castling next storm Queen b5 check but I
just develop
I mean 9 ft 7 on ib7 should be ok both
of those Mo's it's taking a long while
probably kind of kind of wondering what
went wrong because I don't think he has
anything yeah this is a good position to
move maybe maybe the dark squares this
is really this is the only idea yeah ok
I'm going to castle I cannot really take
Queen takes prevents my canceling and
now rooks see one yeah this is this is
probably good for a slight edge for
white maybe very slight edge doing this
oh that's a bit surprising
I did not think about this move at all
okay I'm going to take it we can see for
quite a lot but maybe that's not really
important Queen b6 can also do 94 or
takes here actually and 94 maybe I'm
just taking why not then 94 over here
Knight g4 rather not yeah that is a nice
piece there on e4 okay yeah if I take my
bishop
this is going to be an internal issue
can I play it in a somewhat more active
way 92 to c4 that's actually interesting
maybe
interesting way to play that also
introduces the idea of Queen to g5 Queen
g5m Knight see for these kind of tricks
yeah yeah I may know my bishop hey it
looks really silly but maybe it's not so
important
he's taking enormous amount of time so
Queen g5 yes threatening Knight f3 Queen
III maybe rook c8 all those moves they
look like they helped me I was terribly
slow okay means that 94 he's playing
what exactly look f1 maybe when 92 maybe
the Queen d2 I mean interesting do I
have another move another good move I
don't see one it is interesting Queen d2
okay I was expected didn't expect that I
was thinking yes to prevent that check
threatening the double-check
so yeah 94 lastly noise I yeah it was a
bit strange I was thinking that right
she has to play rook everyone let's only
move and then my idea was Queen d2 which
forces Bishop before and now all of a
sudden this Bishop is is going to do
some things think I'm okay now
yeah this opening I had known yeah I
played I played the wrong move water if
I want to play with g5 I should start
with the move and then play c5 and keep
this here so that I have Bishop a6 in
the right moment this way
I had to react to this I don't think it
was so terrible or anything after system
but uncommon no you went here took ya
and c5 which is a move that is a bit
risky because of my bad development but
maybe it's nothing terrible computer is
saying equal we should be three castles
yeah I'm playing although normally moves
and here yeah here hmm I don't know but
it looks it looks decent no idea form
here now we are 92 it's really a good
movie I'm getting getting there and
after this yeah Queen g5 this is
annoying here and nights before strong
according to the machine
yeah I like this idea
maybe it's it's about equal value check
never this is definitely winning yes so
nice when I'm recovering a little bit
yeah I had this if you yeah sorry I'm
here you know I had my header look at
all those minuses they had an amazingly
bad session and in in the live show yeah
like this all loss loss loss loss loss
and so on it was really terrible and now
I'm recovering a little bit with a
couple of wins okay I hope you enjoyed
this game thanks for watching